travailler chez soi nécessite d'avoir un
espace agréable et aménager qu'il soit
dans le salon dans la chambre ou dans la
cuisine
certains salariés veulent pouvoir être à
l'aise ils font donc appel à des
architectes et décorateurs d'intérieur
l'agent soleil beaucoup demandent depuis
la mise en place du confinement un
salarié qui travaille chez lui de façon
confortable agréable sur un espace qui
est fonctionnel constitue pour sa
société une meilleure valeur ajoutée
c'est clair donc on a besoin d'être bien
pour travail chez cette cliente
un projet de rénovation de la cuisine
avait déjà été entamée mais avec
l'arrivée du confinement et du
télétravail tout a été repensé il ya eu
des variations d'un point de vue
matériaux puisque le client a souhaité
mettre son poing de bureau de travail au
centre névralgique de la maisonnée donc
la cuisine les matériaux étaient
beaucoup plus foncez donc on a apporté
des notes beaucoup plus fraîche et jouer
avec vraiment la lumière pour que
l'espace soit beaucoup plus lumineux un
plan de travail clair des meubles blancs
à la place de bleu canard une grande
verrière ouverte sur le salon et une
décoration épurée
la cliente voit vraiment la différence
avec le début du premier confinement je
me suis retrouvé enfermé dans mes quatre
murs de chambre sur une petite table
ronde comme ça c'était un peu compliqué
et j'avoue que j'ai pas j'ai respiré
quoi quand on a refait notre monde
espace en bas waouh
c'était totalement différent selon une
enquête réalisée par l'agglomération de
saint quentin en yvelines sur 2000
personnes 92 % d'entre elles disent
apprécier de télé travailler sur ce
territoire